hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend podcast that gives much more
than it ever takes don't know what that
means just set it what do you mean I put
no thought into these introductions Sona
nice to see you nice to see you your leg
is get going a little fast today I know
are you nervous about something yeah I'm
really scared to be here I don't know
you might be nervous your leg is going
like a jackam can I be I think I have
too much chocolate before we recorded
and I really think it's like sugar is is
pumping through my we all had a
different place at this round table that
I grew up at in our kitchen and my
mother my seat was next to my mother my
mother was to my right so I was on her
left and I'm a I have a jiggly leg Yeah
restless leg restless leg and it goes
like a jackhammer and my mother used to
just grab it like a vice and squeeze it
and go don't do that people will think
something's wrong with you oh no yes and
so we cleared that up no one's ever
thought something's wrong with me that's
what it was yeah it was that one thing
yeah she didn't tell me don't make
900,000 hours of crazy up content
and put it all over the
Internet kept that leg still maybe if
the leg was going I'd be perfectly
normal maybe you should get a full leg
cast like a cast iron cast on your leg
or then your whole body would start go
fake legs so that my torso goes through
my torso is there but then I just have
fake and then I could like add calf
muscles make them more attractive where
are your legs where your normal legs how
do you get around I don't know have them
removed oh it's not like they're hidden
I should have had them hidden and I
don't know why I went to removed was so
extreme question that that's a bad idea
I don't know I'm just I'm going ahead
with it anyway so this is always yes
I've always had a restless leg and I
don't know why I called you out on yours
because you really don't you're calm
most I'm usually chill what about you
gorle do you have any ticks like that or
any legs actual restless legs condition
at night when you get those horrible
restless legs I don't know what that is
I don't know what that is either it's
like a syndrome it's a thing where you
you get like pin pins and needles and
you can't sleep and your legs feel crazy
oh that sounds serious are you okay I
probably not well you should get checked
out I have there's nothing can be done
about it it's neurological they don't
know what causes it I didn't mean to
bring down lay down your legs have pins
and needles yeah or they feel like
they're like half asleep but you got to
move them even though that doesn't
really help okay I'm going to ask our
listeners if there is a doctor listening
or someone who knows about this
condition could you please contact us
because you might there might be
something going on here how do they
contact us uh I'm sure will tell us
there a phone number that they can leave
a voicemail on I spoke to my doctor I
love I love that we're a podcast that
has a phone number there's a phone
number
1555 wrigly 22
um you've spoken to a doctor I have yeah
was it a good doctor or like some sort
of kooky doctor that you might have it
was a wish doctor I thought so no it was
it was my doctor my general practitioner
everything's fine don't don't it's no
one should have any concern I you're
kept awake at night by pins and needles
feelings in your legs don't go away
that's interesting I don't know what
that is what if it just turns out you
guys have termites oh it's just an
infestation yeah you're really being
eaten alive as you lay in bed at least
there be a solution I'd take it I uh
yeah I have an I have an itchy uh back
like my right shoulder blade and
recently uh my dermatologist said
there's absolutely nothing there and
it's just neurological it's an itch that
isn't there it's a phantom itch oh my
god do you have a back scratcher uh we
did have one then he what's that yeah
fired I found it it's illegal to pay a
man that little to scratch your back
back uh the Better Business Bureau got
involved no I I think my wife found one
and then it went it disappeared and now
I swear to God we'll be watching TV at
night and I'll Stand Up get off the
couch go over to the wall find a corner
and I'll I'm like a bear in the woods I
start raking my back across the edge of
a doorway who because and I'm told it's
quite common it's something that happens
it's neurological it's not real but it
feels real to me we're up yeah
yeah well this is why we've been driven
to this this gig I think you both have
things that like are really not
diagnosable they're just neurological
yeah that's that's weird well I don't
know you might have stuff too you just I
don't think do you go to a doctor and
stuff what do you mean I don't know you
you're you have I know that your parents
are very old school yes they are old
school and you tell me all the time that
your father grew up in a village right
and uh that so I don't know if you grew
up I mean did they I don't know what
happened did they what did you grow up
in a small village you know what we
weren't as dependent on doctors as a lot
of people are but maybe that's a good
thing sure but I also I don't think I
have anything with my body that's like a
neurological thing I mean I feel like
you guys like that should be more
concerning but you're both like H
whatever when you say it's not a bad
thing that you never went to the doctor
as a child yeah you're I said we didn't
rely on doctors as as a lot of people
you said dependent and that's not a bad
thing yeah yeah it's not it's the first
time I met your dad I noticed that he
has a pipe going through his head and I
said what about that pipe and he went oh
it'll it'll go away on its own he said
this this uh truck ahead of me dropped
this off on the highway went through my
head
1969 but it'll be okay how do you pick
on my dad so I love your dad I know he's
got the best mustache I've ever seen my
dad's the best what would their remedy
be for his neurological Phantom
yeah what would your mom say to do cuz I
do trust she has some old like folk
remedies she does have she's very much
in the old sort of like Voodoo thing
like when we wanted to have babies I
think I told you she like buried a baby
under a bush not a real baby not a real
baby s like she should have just given
you the baby a minute a minute you the
baby wait a minute a doll a baby doll
guess what it it works can I say
something you've got to say that you've
got to say that was so upsetting he did
bury the lead so upsetting we really
wanted a baby so she buried a baby in
the backyard what a what a Monster yeah
no was a bush it was a baby doll it was
a doll she buried a doll under a bush
was it one of is it a talking doll no
once we had the boys she was like uh
this it's done it worked can I say
something I was by your house remember
the last time and I was walking around
the backyard and I stepped on what I a
loose piece of grass and I heard
mama mama that baby's still alive no
it's a talking baby where is this baby
so somewhere there's just a dirt crusted
baby sitting in your mom's house or what
yeah probably hundreds of
them
God for every day that Sona was married
for every day Sona was married she would
do
it 900 plastic baby dolls were stolen
yesterday from a Walmart plus a
shovel if police find either one please
report oh man so uh yeah but I don't
know I mean they would I think I really
think you two need to figure out why
these things are happening to your
bodies I think we should talk to your
mom yeah I I think my mom could fix it
we have her in yeah your mother uh
because I've noticed in the past when I
have not felt well you have told me oh
here's what my mom would do and it's it
sounds pretty cool like your mom has
good I'm I'm I'm saying this it sounds
like she has really good remedies for
some things the burying the plastic baby
that there there's a few missteps but
for the most part she's been been pretty
like my brother and I are are are pretty
healthy people like we don't you know we
don't we've been we've we're okay we're
alive yeah you don't sound convincing
yeah we're all alive okay Mr needle legs
and weird itch on my back Phantom itch
Phantom restless legs thank you very
much restless leg you two are up
and you're getting mad at me cuz of the
way I'm dealing with my body sh got mad
at you you come from a very judgy place
I don't think so yes you are you're
coming from a very Jud whole thing
started with you going you guys need to
get that checked out yeah you
went from telling us you got to get that
checked out too my mother buried
a baby in the
backyard that we're allowed to judge by
the way by the way that some judgment is
in order I oh it works I have two
sentencing how do you think my two
children happened you think that just
happened I have a
theory did she bury two
gu she just wanted children of some I
don't think it matters how many you bu
how does this work if you're like I
really want a turkey sandwich do you
just bury a turkey sandwich oh my God no
you just go get a turkey sandwich Matt
that's how it works okay now you have to
bury that sandwich then hope another
sandwich comes and then when that
sandwich doesn't come you have to buy
that sandwich and bury it you die of
starvation with 900 turkey sandwiches
buried underneath the ground go go rub
your back on the
wall go rub your go rub your back I love
that put down go rub your you know what
true story my mother if she was losing
an argument to one of my sisters and I
swear to God I was there for this she
said ah go wash your
face I heard this in like
1970 my sister one of my sisters was
going like no but Mom I she was oh go
wash your face go wash your face there's
a Shakespearean one that's go taste your
legs which means like use your legs run
away go away oh oh I see make use of
your legs I like go wash your face I
like I'm going to use goh face I'm going
to use that on Liza next time she's
talking next time she's saying you know
who how dare you smash all the dishes in
the kitchen which I do occasionally it's
sort of like a Zorba the Greek thing you
know like Yay zor good luck yeah and
then uh she'll I'm going to and she gets
mad at me I'm G to go I go wash your
face I'm going to try it and see how it
works no I don't want you to say to
Eliza but I want to definitely say it to
someone go bury a baby go bury the baby
okay uh dark very dark it is dark you
got to
say plastic baby or baby doll which is
not what you did I know I should have
said that well your own fault
anyway